there's a fella in new york fisher is
his last name
who was suing someone they because he
didn't get uh hired because because he
was white
if you can google that
look that up
yeah yeah this is it
tyler fisher i know him really yeah i
know he's a funny dude does a lot of
impressions great voices wow i think he
was just in the movie uh some movie uh
the daily wire
like the shapiro's production company
he's in that movie that western movie
he's like a big part in it oh wow yeah
yeah it says right here this is
something he tweeted i'm currently suing
a talent manager who told me they
wouldn't work with me because i'm a
white man
they just asked how much money i want to
settle out of court
update i will not settle i will take
this all the way even if i don't get a
dime this justified racism must end he's
going all the way with it i guess
he was trying to find a talent manager
in october when he first connected with
agi entertainment
um
[Music]
i was ready to sign the papers that's
when the conversation took a turn
agi assistant alex brizzle said we love
you everyone here loves you this thinks
you're a star but we're not taking you
because you're white
and that's when my stomach dropped
wow this is interesting he's
he's now swinging the company
in brooklyn supreme court like he's
really doing it that's like the highest
you can go and
obviously but damn yeah that's that's
unbelievable [__] yeah hold on go down a
little bit more can we say anything else
from the article
that's wild that they would say that to
them that's
my therapist always said make sure you
get things recorded so i hit record
during the call
which he took while in his podcast
studio
the only he said he said to him he said
so you guys like me you want to work
with me you know i've got what it takes
but the only reason is because i'm white
and the person responded yeah wow and he
has it on tape damn you got to be
careful with comedians now that we all
got podcast equipment recordings are
going man that's interesting because and
also it lets you know how other people
felt the second you hear that because
i'm white it makes you feel like
how black people must have felt or
mexican or native i mean just anyone
who's never had the opportunity because
of their
because of their skin you know yeah it's
not it's not right no matter
who you're saying it to i felt it when i
was in finland and like
you know because in finland they're like
whiter than they're as white as they can
get yeah on the white scale they go and
there was like some like dudes who were
like drunk and targeting me because they
thought i was like romanian or romy or
something because i'm a little darker
and dark features and big eyebrows and
it felt horrible wow it feels really but
it was like the only time i felt
i guess not white
damn so there is a little something to
this white privilege thing you weren't
white
yeah i wasn't white enough
which made me feel like i was other it
was the only time i really felt other
and uh it's not a good feeling you know
but maybe it's maybe it's a good thing
she should have cut an album
[Laughter]
yeah i should have stayed in finland
they've been there and then [__] just
did my whole hour about that oh you
should have stayed over there no you i
mean you should have played ball or you
should have kind of you know you should
have like
gotten into a that's when talent comes
out of you yeah you know when you're
oppressed when you squeeze yeah yeah
when you squeeze that's when talent
comes out yeah
wow this is going to be interesting
because
he said that a lot of people reached out
to him and said um
privately saying this happened to me i
too am afraid to speak out
the interesting thing is how a lot of
the people that work at these places are
white
yeah and they're the ones saying it yeah
and they're the ones telling people oh
you're white yeah yeah it's weird i have
a little experience with this because
like we were talking about off camera i
had this character that i created that
is trans
and latin
and uh
you know now it's censored on youtube it
has a warning on it and uh the people
who love that character are
trans gay
puerto rican black that's the fan base
for it so it's almost like you know the
warning whoever put that warning on was
probably white going like hey
you know this is bad i get you know
you're like dude have you ever met a
puerto rican person yeah you even know a
trans or gay person
so it's weird yeah
wow i'm really curious to see how this
is going to shake out he said he's not
going to take the money but that money
could get pretty high
everybody could get pretty high yeah
that money could get pretty high maybe
he'll say he'll donate it to the aclu
like amber heard and then he won't
but i guess what would be the equivalent
to the aclu for white guys i don't know
but it does feel weird like if you want
to like talk to your like if you want to
have a meeting for just white guys who
feel a certain type of way you couldn't
do that you know it would be looked down
upon whereas i don't think that's fair
because i feel like you could always
have a meeting for any other ethnicity
even when they were uh when they
actually when they were really feeling
oppression because
you know i mean they surely they were
oppressed yeah but
i feel like you should be if you wanted
to have a meeting with those with
caucasians or with you know some people
that are irish or black and irish or
white or
i met a guy yesterday who was japanese
and native american that guy should be a
he can probably have a meeting you know
yeah
you know what the funny thing is do you
feel like i mean anybody should be able
to i mean now i guess if people are
meeting and saying like
[__] these other people then that ain't
cool well i guess just historically if a
couple white guys get together and they
have a meeting
it's a lot of times it's not good yeah
more if it's more than 10 and they're
just like we're having a meeting you're
just like
what are you guys meeting about of
course of course
but i think i guess i don't know i guess
in my heart i feel like people have
moved on so much from that maybe people
haven't i think mostly most people have
yeah but maybe this is just kind of
karma maybe this is the check coming
yeah for all the bad [__] white people
do it this maybe this will get white
people to feel a little bit what it felt
like and then hopefully like we can all
go okay now we all know but yeah i mean
i guess this is just the consequences of
it i guess but martin luther king didn't
want that right he wants everyone to
just be chill
and like
character is based on your character not
what you look like but
yeah i mean look it's definitely even
like touring certain places you see that
like the damage that like colonization
and stuff called it just in like
you know and even when i think like
would it be better to be back at our
roots like and it'd be like literally
like you know
you know wishing that
that we had more of the native
connection to our land and stuff that it
seemed like maybe we once did
you know as humans
yeah the native americans are definitely
more in balance with nature for sure
yeah but also it's like the white people
don't care about other white people
that they like this whole thing where
they make us a monolith and think we're
all like why people don't care yeah like
when a white dude gets killed or
something like there's no white people
meat like
irish people don't care about italians
you know like greeks don't care about
italians like
regular americans aren't thinking about
italian-americans like we're not unified
like they're you know what i mean yeah
like you have that great joke where
you're going like uh where you're like
you think i would take your [__] move
right next door to you and just not have
it yeah like somebody else has both
their [__] you just like you have no
connection to this [__] you didn't do
anything you know what i mean you just
uh i don't give
my people don't care about your people
right your people gotta like if
something happened there was like a hate
crime in louisiana against white people
against like your type of whites i don't
know what they would call those
louisiana
something yeah neighborhood whites i
guess yeah they were just good old the
greeks would be like we would just go
back to the diner or whatever yeah we
wouldn't even think about it yeah we're
not like one
right i get yeah i mean it's all it's
all real real interesting i don't know
it is interesting when
um but yeah i mean i think the
it's interesting because you do get an
immediate idea of what it probably felt
like of like oh wow people can't
do this you know i'm not allowed to do
this i mean that's the [__] thing
that drives everybody for anything yeah
you know one uh one thing that's really
like i don't know i mean i will always
envy in some ways certain cultures and
ethnicities because they have the best
origin story
it's like damn you got the [__]
you know
it's inside of you to [__] want to do
something it's baked into your jeans
because you have people that couldn't do
it
like [__] man i would love you know and
maybe i have some of that but i would
love to have you know that's the [__]
sauce baby you're right like even
even when it comes to like the sexual
stuff we were talking
like someone who becomes a sexual a
professional
sex worker or porn star there was
something maybe in their life they
didn't get and now they
they've become great at that yeah i mean
they're great at [__] they're like
they take it to another it's an art form
because yeah i mean
yeah like does anyone become great who
was born with everything a healthy
family like if steve jobs wasn't biden
that's what happens yeah i'm just
checking i mean any i don't know who the
[__] knows but if steve jobs wasn't
[__] dropped on a doorstep in a
basket would we have we wouldn't have
apple yeah he wouldn't have the
motivation to be apple if he wasn't like
you know he wasn't roaming out of the
gate yeah if he wasn't [__] stevie
left in a basket oh stair step stevie
huh yeah so they called him that
stoop steve stoops
easy stupid steve hope you enjoyed that
video and you can watch another and you
can watch this one you can watch this
one different options different choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy two
options watch one this one or this one